all right folks
uh welcome to this month's meetup see a
lot of people are trickling in the room
i never know zoom if it's actually
letting in people one at a time or just
iterating the counter to make it look
like this activity
to cover up some sort of server lag or
something so let's give a little bit for
everyone the counter to keep ticking up
words
and we'll get started in just a few
minutes in the meantime we can all sit
here awkwardly staring at each other in
silence the four people on screen
or we can make small talk banter like um
who's that coffee clutch on snl
yeah the clunk lady know him you know
the answer
i do not is a peanuts neither pee nor
not disgust and she's also cleansed
it's mike myers please her nope no idea
someone messing all knows this
hi jim from chicago thanks for joining
us
where else is everybody else from let us
know where you're from uh jump in here
tell us where you're coming from so now
that
we're all virtual people are coming from
all over the world we have people from
all over the states and other countries
depends
um i did say i'll make this announcement
again later ah
valentina still in nyc i like to see
that
um we have oh we have uh collins
colorado from
brian and we have a slack channel i
might have posted the link in there
to join it and you can go ahead and uh
use a slack for conversation as we'll go
over in a little bit
uh so uh some things are going to cut
off i see san francisco
the other williamsburg i like that maybe
the original actually
i don't know which williamsburg is older
because like williamsburg virginia does
have colonial williamsburg
but williamsburg brooklyn goes back to
the dutch days so it's
kind of hard to say which one is older
i'm sure someone has that answer here
melbourne someone from melbourne nice i
can't see the uh the full name though
but that's probably gonna hold the
record for the farthest away
san francisco jersey
very cool oh new haven of course
with their facility of new york pizza
but they're going to call pizza and it
is pizza but it's a pizz
but it's no new york pizza even though
they use a coal oven
all right okay so well let me start
slowly with the announcements
um so i see have posted again um if
you're in here
join our slack team you can get to it by
going to uh the link
i'm not opposed to two links you get to
it from either one ny hackard.org
slack.html or go directly to the slack
invite link
go on there and this beyond tonight we
have all sorts of community
announcements on there all sorts of
information is available on that slack
team
so before we get going first things we
always like to do is
we always like to say who is hiring but
during the pandemic we can't just have
everyone sort of
shouting in here it would be a little
too difficult so if you can go into the
slack
team that ahmad has sent a link to and
there is a channel specifically called
job postings go in there and post your
job
and tag it that you're here tonight we
also have a channel for tonight's meetup
i believe it's called november 9th
meetup
roughly along those lines um and you can
post jobs there but i highly recommend
putting into the job postings
also to catch everyone one of the nice
benefits of eco health alliance
sponsoring us
every month by providing the zoom link
is that noam has some
jobs he'd like to announce and since
he's right here with us he helps host us
every month he's going to say some of
the jobs he has waiting for everybody
sure thanks jared so uh eco health
alliance is happy to have been
uh new york r's virtual host
uh for the past seven months or so when
we were
in physical space we were unable to fit
you all into our offices but now our
home we're happy to
uh provide a little infrastructure for
everyone
so ecohealth alliance is a non-profit
based in new york city
that works on pandemic prevention and
wildlife conservation
and we work uh on emerging infectious
diseases globally
and locally and right now we have a
bunch
of job opportunities at ecohealth
ranging from a data scientist position
on my team to more intro level positions
of
project research assistants and research
scientists
all of which uh have r as some component
of the job from project managers uh for
whom
some data management and some analysis
is part of the portfolio
uh to data scientists who will primarily
be coding and building infrastructure
data pipelines and
models for coronavirus modeling and
response
so i'd encourage anyone interested in uh
environmental
or public service or public health
fields to check out the job postings i
just put
in the job channel and uh feel free to
contact me on the new york r slack if
you have questions about
any of them these are the ones up now
there will be several other new ones in
the coming months
so do keep an eye out thank you very
much
thank you noam both for hosting us and
for the jobs if you can imagine
anything right now a organization that
helps prevent pandemics global pandemics
i think that's a really great place to
work right about now
so uh thank you also for trying to
prevent or lessen the pandemic also
everyone give noam a virtual round of
applause for getting ahead of this those
who don't know
actually gave our first pandemic talk um
in april
virtually because he's an expert in this
stuff uh so thank him for all the work
he's doing
and i'll see if everyone's hopefully
virtually clapping for him in the chat
thank you known uh so thank you
saying yes it's it's great having you
again everyone also thank you eco help
alliance for sponsoring us everyone
hosting us
it's really a big help having them do it
so thank you on that
people who have been coming to us meet
up for a while know that we really take
our pizza seriously
so if everyone is having pizza virtually
uh this month i got it from newtown
pizza
you can see i got a cheese slice and
what their
various historical reasons so this is
newtown pizza specifically of the
trenton pie next to their plane slice
um you can see there's a decent charring
on the back considering it's a gas oven
not cold charred or wood chunks it's
good for a gas oven
so i hope everyone's enjoying their
pizza wherever they're getting it from
let us know in the chat
where you're getting pizza from this
month we always like to know about that
as always when i know mata got
williamsburg pizza recently
and we'll see where everyone else is
getting pizza from
let us know it's always fun to chat
about pizza
uh as i was saying earlier uh we can't
all ask questions the way we normally
would
i'm just gonna put the pizza down for a
second sorry for the weird leaning over
uh we can't all ask questions like we
normally would in person so if everyone
can
meet channel ask your questions in there
and we will collate the questions and
ask them later
for you uh depending on how many
questions you get in the middle we might
ask some questions in the middle of the
talk
or we might save them for the end it
depends how the talk's going
there's a lot of questions people need
answered we will work on the best way
either
during the talk or after and get all
your questions answered so please go
ahead either in the zoom chat
or in the meetup chat and let us have
your questions
we have the next few months planned out
in terms of meetup we actually have a
pretty full schedule
but next month is our big r week
normally
in addition to the new york r conference
every spring summer this year
we have a washington dc conference since
we're not going to be there physically
we're doing it virtually just like nyr
was
but it is actually very more focused
less on the geography of dc
and more on the concept of dc and
government in general
it is now the r in government and public
service conference
and we have a full week almost a full
week pack of activities
uh to be kickoff our week we have
december 1st
we have will landau talking about the
targets package
if you came a few months ago for uh
miles mcbain's talk about drake
will wrote both drake and targets and
targets is the future replacement of
drake
that'll be december 1st we're really
excited then
december 2nd will be a day of workshops
to go with
the r and government conference we have
three workshops we have malcolm barrett
and lucy d'agostino mcgowan
teaching a workshop on causal inference
we have cass sakamoto teaching mapping
for public policy
and john hirsch teaching machine
learning for public policy so that's
december 2nd
and then december 3rd through 4th is
actual r and government conference
we have speakers from nasa from the
census bureau from the department of
defense
from canada's defense ministry we have
people from new york city department of
health and human services
we have i think some educators we have
uh
people from zurich i believe working on
the working on covid
we have people from all over the world
speaking all about public policy whether
that's
federal state local provincial different
countries different levels of government
um it's going to be a really exciting
conference really putting a lot of hard
work into making this as lively as nyr
was
we instead of a whiskey sponsor this
time we have a rum
and gin sponsor we have a panel
we're going to have a lot of cool events
we have the art auction we already have
a bunch of art being
donated and just like nyr all the
proceeds from the art auction
is going to be donated to the r
foundation so the money goes to a
nice cause i think we all believe in
here if you want to learn more you can
go to rstats.ai
gov oh i'm already posted a link great
and you can use discount code ny hack
are for 20 discount
so go to rstats.ai gov use your 20
20 discount and come have a fun time i
think anyone who comes to my conferences
knows that they are
fun and informative so we're gonna have
a really good time
all right uh with that we bring our
speaker who
is on the r foundation which is a nice
segue
and is on the our consortium and is
coming to us all the way from the west
coast
to talk to us about futures in our
so please everyone give a warm welcome
to henrik thank you very much for being
here everyone
thank you very much
thank you so much hi everyone
i'm about to share my screen here
there we go to clean up
um i'm very i'm very grateful for
giving this opportunity to talk i wish i
could see you all
in person as probably a lot of
speakers been saying on virtual talks
it's like it's kind of awkward to speak
into the void but i'm
trying i know you're out there listening
um so i'm going to talk about the future
package in the future framework it's
meant to be a simple friendly
framework for parallel processing in r
my background is computer science i did
a mathematical
phd in mathematical statistics
for various places in the world
including wonderful melbourne and wehi
and berkeley i ended up at ucsf
in san francisco so i'm in the fb
biostat
department where i'm a faculty there i
spent most of my days
on cancer research in the cancer center
there
and i do a lot of computational
large-scale
processing so what i'm presenting here i
would say
grew out out of work that started back
in 2005.
i tried to paralyze on my windows
computer at the time then linux i had
collaborators all over the world
and we developed methods for microarray
data sequencing
and our methods in r
we wanted them to work for everyone so
slowly i added parallelization
frameworks and i build up things and
this is kind of the final product
of those things you can find me on
twitter github and i have a
blog post to jotter.org where you can
see
a little bit where blogging about the
future framework
okay so um
why do we paralyze
we paralyze things when we try to speed
the existing code up as much as possible
and we can't
get the results faster so then we look
into our things
can we run certain things in parallel
here so
this animation here is actually pretty
good
if you look at this there are both
parallel tasks and
sequential tests going on here so each
of the wheels are replaced
but if you look at one of the wheels
they unscrew the wheel
they pull off the old tire they put on a
new tire and
screw the new tire back on so a lot of
things
things can happen in parallel and things
can happen in sequential and we can
orchestrate that
and we can do that in r we can do it
with the future framework 100
so why do we paralyze so one thing was i
said it's like to speed up processing
time so
things finish faster the wall time is
shorter
other things we do is when we have very
large data sets
we might not be able to process all of
the data on a single machine
we can do it we can chunk up the data
and process sequential h chunks
where we can also take the chunks and
distribute them out to multiple machines
and have them run at the same time and
bring back the results later
there might also be other reasons like
asynchronous user interfaces like shiny
in our
so there are different reasons but the
most common one is to
speed things up okay so
i don't know your background who's
listening out there
so i'm going to try to see cover what's
already available in r
and back in 2014
we got the parallel package that's
distributed with all
our installations so we all have this
available so
let's start let's take this toy example
we have a list here with three elements
a b and c and each of these elements
contain 50
integers and
we probably all been here from the first
day we started to use r
someone's uh we did things like this we
wanted to calculate the sum of each of
these elements and store them in a new
list
so we created a list we calculated the
sum of element a
in x assign it to a in the y
list and so on for b and c
and then quite soon we realized okay if
there are new elements added this is not
going to work
very well so then we turn to for loops
and this is a pretty good for loop we
create a list
we iterate all over all the names in the
x list
and then we calculate the sum for each
of these elements and we assign it to
the y
with the same name so this works uh
it's very verbose it depends where
you're coming from you might like this
some people might think it's too much
code too much clutter
but it's very clear what what it's doing
here
and then we know there is in r there are
apply functions so
in base r we have the l apply function
list apply
so the same task can be done with this
we call
l apply on the vector capital x and we
say
apply the function sum and return a new
list
in y so all these alternatives will give
the same results here
and one thing is interesting to see here
is that the
l apply when you just look at it from
the outside
there is nothing saying which order
things will be done
it could be that l apply decide to do it
in the order of b
c and a as long as it returns it a b c
we're all happy
okay so r has the parallel package
so um if say we have this
function called slow sum so we calculate
the
each of the summations of the
elements will take one minute so doing
it from three elements will take
three minutes if we use hill apply
so we can use the parallel package and
there is the mcl apply which is
multi-core
l apply so that's how you use this
and here in this case we're saying let's
use three cores on our local machine
and since each of the tasks will take
one minute each
and they run in parallel this will now
finish within one minute
this is good if you're in unix on mac
but if you're on windows
this will fall back to a regular l apply
and this is because it's using fork
processing which r doesn't support on
windows
however we have options to paralyze also
windows
um or if you want to do something that
works on all operating systems so this
last example here is works on all
operating system
where we create a cluster of three
workers we pre-created so that actually
launches
three processes that run in the
background and are ready to serve
tasks that we send it send them
and the way we send those tasks is for
the par el apply function
so it looks very similar to l apply we
just specify
what the cluster is the cluster of
workers and this was also run in
parallel for three three tasks at the
same time
finishing one minute so this is good um
there are a few things we need to be
aware of um
let's look at the mcl apply um so it's
great because it looks exactly like
apply
it comes with all our installation so
you know it's it's there
and one thing i will return to later
it's like we don't have to worry about
global variables and loading packages
it just works and the reason why it
works is using
this concept of fork processing that is
a construct in the operating system
so everything is taken care of
automatically by the operating system
and that's the unfortunate thing it
doesn't work on windows
another thing is there are cases where
this might actually crash or car dump
your r session
um it's not 100 clear when it is
happening but there are several reports
coming in and i'm saying it's not clear
it's not clear to me there are people
that knows
very well how this works but we see this
is like
when there is code that is
multi-threaded and multi-threading is
something that's done in native code
it's not done at the r level so there's
already
multi-threading going on and then you
paralyze on top of that
there might be things that doesn't work
when you do fork processing
and they're also like the environment
you're running in
so for instance people been saying that
rstudio console
you might actually crash that if you run
mcl apply
not all the time but in some cases so
mcl applies kind of you have to know
uh you have to use it with a care and
this is a quote from april 2020
from simon urbanek who wrote them
sealapply in his part of our core
so he said do not use mc parallel that's
one of the function
multi-core mcapply structure
don't use that in packages except as a
non-default option
that users can set so that means
if you have a function you should not
one thing you should not run mcl apply
by default
and that should be the choice of the
user so then you can as a developer you
can be sure it will work
and the ones who want to take the chance
to try it
they can try it and it's meant for hpc
applications that need to use many core
as possible for computational heavy jobs
but it does not play well with rstudio
and more importantly you or we as
developers
don't know the resources available that
the user has
so only the user can tell you when it's
safe to use it
so i just want to erase that it's like
it's a wonderful function
but you might run into very complicated
hard to troubleshoot errors
okay let's look at the par l apply
solution
which works on all platforms
just like mcl apply it works very
similar to l apply
comes with all our installations and all
operating systems
the drawbacks here are is like you have
to manually load packages on the workers
you create
and you also have to make sure you
export all the variables and globals
to the workers i'll show you an example
here
it's a bit convoluted but bear with me
it's a it's a it's a toy example so in
the d player package there is the star
wars
data framework table it contains the
name
of the characters in star wars their
height the weight
homeworld and the species so let's say
we want to
calculate the average height
on all the humans and the average height
of all the droids
so and this is what i mean it's a
it's a toy example because deep player
can do this very well but here i'm going
to use l apply for this
so i'm going to l apply over the droid
and the humans
so i'm going to pass a function that
takes those
as an argument and then
i'm going to use the filter function in
deep plier
on the star wars table and subset
either droid or human and when i've done
that i'm going to take out the column
height and i'll calculate the mean value
and removing uh missing values
so if i do that and then i look at the
unlisted version of the result here it's
going to be
the mean height of the drawings will be
centimeters i guess and the um is 176.
so if we try to do this same thing with
power he'll apply
um it looks very similar and we just
replace the l apply with parallel apply
we're going to get this
the workers or the nodes will complain
saying i don't know what the
this star wars object is and if it knew
that it would start complaining about
filter this is because
we need to tell each of the workers to
load the libraries multiplier so this is
how we do this
we do a cluster evaluation across all
the workers since they load
the player package and
now it will work okay
so we need to load packages here's
another example
of this from this example let's say now
we take
create a utility function called average
height
that encapsulate this complicated
expression that we subset
etc and we try to reuse this
in our parallel apply internally
so that's a neater expression cleaner
so and it worked before so we expect
this to work again but no
now the workers are going to complain
that i don't know what average height is
and that is because that was only
defined in your
local environment your main r session
and what's evaluated within the parallel
apply is running on the workers
so we need to pass that function we need
to export that function
and then it works so
parallel applies nice but it comes with
this extra orchestration and
clutter it up clutters up your code a
little bit
um okay so let's see then
um if you're a package developer and you
want to like support
parallel processing um we we
i've gone through what i'm going to show
now if you pull out a
package in cran that uses mcl apply or
parallel apply or both
you will see what these examples so the
first one is like
so let's say you have a function called
let's go back to the slow sum now forget
about the star wars
so we want to calculate the
we call slow sum on each of the elements
on an x
and then we take unlist and sum that so
that basically is a function called
total sum
so if you have this original list with
three vectors we call
total slow sum and we're going to get
the sum of all this
and it will work by its first summing
one to 50 51 to 100
and then this and then take the sum of
those
okay so now you have this is in a
package
on cran and you want in since it's slow
we're looking into paralyzation
and this might be the first iteration so
this is quite common thing you see
on cram packages you add
option that the
user can say parallel equal to true or
false
whether they want to paralyze or not and
the way we do it if parallel
is true we call mcl apply
and in this example it's saying calls
the detect course that use all the cores
in the machine
and if i forgot to say that later don't
do this this is
a bad habit not very friendly
and if you don't run in parallel we fall
back to using l apply
and then we end by summing
of this intermediate results so from the
end user's point of view is very clean
you call total slow sum and the end user
can call either parallel equal to true
or false and they will get the same
result
and then so here's a better example
i said don't use detect course
it's actually better to just don't
specify that
and let the user specify the number of
cores for in our options
so then the user can control exactly how
many course they want to use
if they want to spare some course for
other tasks etc
okay another style you can see it's that
instead of having parallel equal to true
or false
is that you
package developer provide an argument
called ncourse and saying how many
parallel cores you want to run so the
default is one
and that means it will fall back to usl
apply
but if the user specified two three or
four more
they were run with mcl apply and
regardless you get the same results okay
so then the windows users so now we want
to support windows users too
because we don't want to leave windows
users out and
so this is what the code will expand to
if the user asks for more than one core
then you can check
my running on windows yes
then we can create a cluster with n
course workers
we're really good citizen here so if
this function when this function
exits regardless if it is an error or
successful
it will shut down the cluster at the end
if this slow function would
depend on some library or
globals they have to be exported as well
and then we called par l apply uh
if you're not on windows that is like
linux solaris
or mac we can use the mcl apply forked
or if we don't want to do
parallelization we fall back to l apply
okay fine
and then you're sure you're going to get
users if your pack is a popular
hey can you please add support for the
aaa parallelization method too
and then someone else is like oh while
you're doing that can you add the bbb
support and if you look at this
uh the previous example this
parallelization is all on your local
computer so the first thing you might
actually get
requests from is to paralyze across
multiple computers
so we need to adjust this code for that
so you might end up with something like
this now you don't no longer have true
false
you have a string where you specify what
type of realization so you can parallel
with snow that's the general term for
these parallel applied solutions
and here is a way you use whatever the
end user has set
you ex load packages export global so
you call
this across the workers if the user
requested multi-core
use mcl apply maybe someone want to use
the cluster mq package
backend which allows you to paralyze on
hpc
and that has also arguments for
exporting
exporting globals and loading packages
or
there might be other parallelization
back-ends and finally if we don't want
to paralyze we do the sequential
so and this is not just toy examples
you will find packages that do this and
i did this in the beginning back in
2005 and my my package exploded
i created utility function to
encapsulate this but
start to become tedious and then after a
while you say
i'm adding all these things but i can't
test all these
parallel back-ends i don't have access
to them so you start wondering what's
the test coverage
here i mean i
might trust the mcl apply because i'm on
linux i can run this
and i can run this but i might not have
access to this
so these are like for me unknowns
and if it's unknown to me i can test
them that will be
it's an unknown for the user so the user
it will be risky for the user to run
this because in the end of the day
key thing here is like we always want to
make sure we
get the proper results back
and of course even if you're happy five
years from now there will be someone
come hey there's a new cool
parallelization method out there can add
this and i'm sure you there's a lot of
package developers that will ignore
those requests
so it's it's a tedious thing when you
want to start supporting parallelization
so the summary of this is basically that
as a developer you want to say you want
you need to know what parallel
apis are available and which one should
i use
what operating system are the users
running on
and you might decide i don't have access
to windows i can't be bothered to
develop and test on that
or you get requests back and you're like
oh it should have worked but then oh
i didn't test on mac os and there's
something weird there
and likewise for the users they will say
i wish the developer could spend time to
just add mcl apply
option or something like that because
this awesome package
is too slow but if you can paralyze it
it's great
and there might be people on windows
users that
can't paralyze and also
the fact that the test coverage it's
like
you you see this a lot in on stack
overflow
someone posts an example and
users say it doesn't work for me i get
this error and how to say funny it works
for me
and there's a lot of discussion back and
forth before they figure out they're
actually running on different
operating systems that cause slightly
different differences
so it's there are some tedious things we
have to deal with
okay so this is the reason why the
future framework came about
um i'm going to take a break here to
drink
okay so the future framework
is implemented the core of it is
implemented in the package called future
it's uh the motto is right ones run
anywhere
it's targeted to 100 cross-platform
supposed to work with any type of
parallel back-end so we'll return to
that
what that means it's uh it's supposed to
be as
simple as possible unifying api
and it shouldn't be much more than
what's really needed
it's very easy to install it's small
and i say it's very well tested you get
lots of cpu mileage
and for developers and users it's
supposed to provide low friction so for
instance we saw the global variables
they are automatically exported
identified
uh output from print and things like
that and message and warnings
they are relayed and shown properly and
there's a concept
i won't cover today but feel free to ask
about it
it's random number generation because
that's a very important things if you do
statistics
and you run things in parallel
so what is the future so first of all
i didn't invent it i reinvented it or
rediscovered it
it was invented in the mid 70s
in the field of computer science so
very theoretically a future is an
abstraction it is a programming
construct
for a value that will be available at
later time
the state of the future is either
unresolved or resolved
and the value of the future is the
result
of an evaluated expression so this is a
little bit
like a schrodinger's cat we basically
put an expression in the box
and we close the box and we don't really
know if it's
resolved unresolved or the cat is alive
or dead
and then when we open the box then we
know
so if we look at r
let's look at a very simple construct in
r that's the r assignment
so it has a left hand side here the
letter v
an assignment operator and a right-hand
side an expression
and this expression can be simple as one
plus two it can be function call or it
can be
a bigger construct but the key here when
r
sees this expression it gets to this
line
of code it takes the right-hand side
evaluates it and assigned it to the
variable
named v and it does that in one
in one step so if you look at the future
api
it splits this up in two steps
so you create the future
of the expression the right-hand side
and you say
here is an expression please evaluate it
and you get a handle back to
f and the thing is that
we don't have to ask the value if you
don't want to but later in the code
maybe the next line or much later we say
please give me the value of this future
we're going to get the value back
and by splitting up this very simple
construct of an assignment into two
steps we can do a lot of powerful things
i'll show you next so if we go back to
the slow sum
example there we know that if we
calculate the sum of 100 it will take
two minutes so if we
and because of the how addition works
we can split them up divide and conquer
not all problems can be done this way
but we can sum of 100 can be done in two
steps
the first step is to calculate the sum
of 1 to 50
which will take about a minute and we
assign that to a
and we can take the sum of the last 50
values
and assign that to b so we didn't
gain anything in performance here but we
split
we managed to split this up in two parts
we divided the problem
and we can sum it up later and we get
the same results
so with futures we can do this so we
load a future package
we tell it to use multi-session that
means paralyze on your local computer
and instead of calculating the value
immediately we
say it calculated in a future and when
we do this construct it will return
immediately
and since we run this in parallel this
calculation will go off
in a background r session and start
running
and then we can do the same for the last
50 values and it will return immediately
as well
and at this point we have to background
our processing
doing its calculation and our prompt in
the
maynard session is free to do other
things so we can toy around here
and and then when we board
say like 45 seconds later we say
okay what's the value of the first
future that's how we do this
we say given the value of the first
future and since we only
waited 45 seconds that one needs another
15 seconds to complete
so after 15 seconds it will return
and then since we can do the same for b
and since that run
about the same time it's already done
and now we can calculate some of those
things
so what we gain here is that now we get
to the result
already after one minute so
the construct of the future managed to
spawn things off in the background and
then we have
called the function value to bring back
the results
and if you think this is too verbose
there's actually something called a
future assignment operator
that will allow you to do this so when
we do
um a future assign slow sum
this will be created with instantly and
spawn off in the background same for b
and technically in r these are promises
and the promising r as long as you don't
touch it
nothing will happen but as soon as we
touch it
the promise will go and resolve the
future so it will internally call value
of a
if i touch a if i touch vehicle value of
b and if i say a plus b
that would um like this they will block
until a and b already and we get the
results
but this almost looks like regular
sequential code but it runs in parallel
and key thing here um
it's the end user that choose how to
paralyze so
if we don't specify anything everything
runs sequentially
we can say the end user can say i want
to use multicore
that's the mcl apply machinery
and they can use multi-session which is
the parallel apply machinery
if they have access to three local
machines on the local network
and they have ssh axis into that and
they run
they can run r over ssh this one will
set up
three workers on three different
machines and
your these expressions here will now be
run on two different machines
you can also paralyze have
one local machine one at the university
and maybe one in the cloud
you can have multiple in the cloud etc
if you have access to high performance
compute
clusters you have so-called job
schedules there
there's a back end from the batch tools
package
so here is like what it would look like
if you would
use a slurm scheduler so the end user
would just say i want to parallelize
this on a on the job scheduler you can
use the call our package
which is very similar to the
multi-session
um but it has
it's uh it can do you can run more
uh parallel call r this one has a limit
of
multi-session has a limit of 125 workers
that's an r limitation with call r you
can have more
okay so what about global variables
so i said that global variables are
taken care of automatically so
how is that done so it works
automatically
it works worry free in most cases
there are corner cases that people run
into
and we try to fix them and some some of
them we can't fix
um so in the cases where we can't fix i
just want to say here at the very end at
the bottom
you can provide guidelines to the
package
uh to help it if you don't like the
automatic one you can explicitly specify
everything
or you can say ignore this global
variable or make sure you get this one
so
uh i think the api supports where
whatever you like to do here but the
default is to do it automatically
and so if we have this code example
that we draw a 100
uni gaussian random numbers and
assign it to the vector x and then we
calculate slow sum of that
random vector and we use do that within
the future so this might
run locally parallel locally on your
local machine or it might be
running in the cloud somewhere in the
world
so what the future framework does
it do a static code inspection of this
and this is an example if you use the
prior package with it actually looks
like there's
abstract syntax tree of this r
expression it contains the curly
brackets
so that's these two together the left
and right color brackets
next it sees a function call where the
function is slow sum
and the first argument is x so by
walking this abstract tree
it can go freeze okay the curly brackets
that's part of
base r i don't need to worry about that
function calls i don't need to worry
about but
slow sum that might be something
i need to figure out do i need to export
it or not and if it finds this as
yes it needs to be exported it exports x
needs to be exported
in this process also identify what name
spaces needs to be loaded on the other
on the workers so that's how
global identification is happening
taking place
okay so
so i mentioned that the future api is a
minimal api
so it basically contains on the two
functions you already seen the future
and the value function
and there's one more function called
resolved
that function you might need sometimes
depends what you are but it allows you
to
peek and query a future and basically
are you done yet or not
and it will will not block so you can if
the future is
being resolved on a remote computer that
result will go out and check
are there results available for that
future already or not
and return true or false but
the key thing here is like with only
these three constructs
we can do a lot of powerful things and
here is the very first example
so you can create your own parallel l
apply now
using just future and value you don't
have to use
resolved that comes if you want to do
more fancy things but
you don't have to so
this function um maybe i should show the
example first
so this is how a user would use it they
say let's
um i want to run it on a multi-session
that's parallel on a local computer and
i want to do l apply
on this list x and call slow sum
what happens in here now if you look at
the
inside of the parallel l apply the slow
sum
is this generic function this argument
fun and what we do here is the first
step we use
l apply we could use a for loop here too
but i use an l apply
over all the elements on x
i call this function
with the element x
and any optional arguments however i did
within a future
so this first l apply call here will now
return a list of futures
and when i got that list of futures
i would just say okay now on this list
of futures
give me the value and
there are several things happening here
if you have enough
if you have more parallel workers and
you have elements in x
this con first l apply will return
immediately
however if you have more elements then
you have parallel workers
it's not going to spawn off
much more workers in parallel than you
have so it will hold back
so the future call if you get to the
fifth future calling you
only have four workers the fifth call
would wait
until there is a worker available but
that will just
that's taken care of by the future
package
so it's
the the point here is that it's given
these
two constructs is very simple to create
higher level mapreduce parallelization
frameworks
and i want to say this is of course is a
it doesn't solve everything it doesn't
take care of random number generation
etc and
load balancing so we need to worry about
that but
it will work and will run in parallel
okay so very early on i added the future
dot apply package which basically
provides futurized version of all the
base r l apply
v apply t apply replicate and so on
and the only thing you have to do if you
already have code that
calls l apply and you figure it's like
this runs
takes a long time to run i want to
parallelize it you basically load this
package and prepend that thing
with future underscore and it will work
there will be cases where it struggles
to find global variables
but it's in this works most of the times
out of the box
um and then again the user
picks i want to paralyze locally across
multiple machines or in a job scheduler
we have also the fur package
by davis it's
futurized versions of pers map map to
modify etc functions
and it's very similar to a previous
example it provides
it works on all parallel backends load
balancing
proper random number generation and all
you need to do is just prepend that
map with future underscore and call
future underscore map
and if you happen to like the for each
framework and a lot of people discover
the for each framework when they want to
do their first parallel processing
um i have uh do future backend or
adapter
to for each
so you basically all you need to do is
register that back end
and use do par and
this for each call will now evaluate
slow
sum using the future framework so
internally there will be
future and value and resolve done and
then the user
can decide to use whatever back-end they
want
so the point is here
thanks to these three very basic
constructs we can very quickly
build up higher level parallelization
map produce
apis so if you like base r you can use
future
dot apply package to paralyze if you
like the tide reverse per you can use
the fur
package if you like for each you can do
this
and there might be other
coming uh for instance if you like
the now deprecated plier package
uh it works also automatically through
the
to future framework if you use bioc
parallel you can also use do future
so you can use that favorite mapreduce
api you like
but you can still run it on top of the
future framework
and whatever back end it supports okay
so let's see
so one thing that's been added over the
last two years is handling of output
warnings
and errors errors been supported from
very early days but um so
let's show some examples here so
if we do this
if we do l apply over a vector of minus
1
10 and 30 and we inside that function
call we
display we use message to show its value
and we calculate the log of that value
we will get this output
we will see it's stepping through the
three elements
and we will also get a warning because
log of -1
is not a number
now if we use mcl apply
different people will have different
success here but
i if i recall correct if you do this in
r studio you won't see anything
if you run it in terminal you might see
that but
i don't think you get the warning at all
and this is because both the
message and the output and the warnings
are
generated on the worker and they never
reach your main art session
they stay with that on that other and
that's the same with parallel apply
so but with the future framework
and that's taken care of in at the very
core level of futures
so this works with future apply for
do future
output is captured standard output is
captured
messages warnings all conditions are
captured
so we will get the same
output as you would do with the regular
apply and this output
is a real output in your main r session
so you can actually capture it
so here is a similar example where i
replace the message with an
sdr and that sensed output to
standard output and i use
capture output i wrap the whole call in
capture output so
this function in r this is base r in the
utils package
it will record everything into variable
standard out
that it sees on standard output
so when i this one will
first generate the warning because the
warning goes through but it captures
everything
from the three steps str into a vector
so that shows that the standard output
reaches you regardless if this
again this might run on the other side
of the world on the computer
and it reaches you on your on your end
and that's the same with
conditions so now i drop this sdr and i
just calculate log
and of course the first
element would be a warning and i can use
a try catch
on my end and this warning generator and
the remote worker
will be relayed back to me i captured a
warning i bump
up this warning to an error and i get an
error
so this is exactly what you could do
with a regular l apply
but you can't do this with m c l apply
or parallel apply or for each
so you can do it with for each if you
use the do future backend
okay so
can you trust this framework am i just
telling you
all the paradise here is it does it
actually work
so there are things that
people run into and we try to solve them
and certain things we can solve
but i want to show you the way i'm
thinking about this
development it grew out of small things
that
didn't work in mcl apply parallel apply
relaying output warnings etc features
you want to have
that adds a lot of frictions if you
don't get them
so this is how i think about it
and hopefully that gives trust to both
end users and developers so
if you use future apply or fur or do
future or whatever will come around
that to high level future frontends or
if you just use the
basic future value functions um
that you can trust that the the future
api
guarantees that regardless of back end
you use if you use the built-in parallel
package and
the different packets we have there call
our batch tools or
whatever we get it will work the same
and how can we know that so of course we
run a lot of tests so there is something
called the back and confirmation test
so the different back ends has to pass
a lot of tests um it's similar to the
the dbi package for databases
they're different database back-ends and
they run confirm
conformance test for those to make sure
they meet all the requirements so you
don't
you can switch out the back ends that's
the same thing here in the parallel
processing
i would say it's very well tested
testing as much as possible and
if you run into bug that bug becomes a
new test case etc
so point here is as a developer you
don't have to worry you can use future
apply for
a new future and you should just trust
that
it will work everywhere and users also
you don't have to say oh
i can i dare to run it on my hpc
scheduler will i get the same results
because we in the end of the day
the results are critical especially in
statistical analysis
um so that the goal here is that the
future api will take care of you
in this sense and
this the package been on crans in 2015
it's been adopted by several bigger
packages like drake plummer shiny
um and of course with those there comes
a lot of
end-users and real-world testing we also
get tested on all the platforms possible
through cran also on various
continuous integration services testing
on all the new versions
of r and go back really far i think 3.1
or 3.2 reverse dependency checks is now
up to 140 packages
and those tests i use the wrapped up
package
awesome package and i can also because
i'm in control of the future api
i can set an environment variable that i
can
test across all different type of
backends even if those
cram packages and by contact packages
don't test across those back-ends i can
run their
checks with a different back-end than
they intended and that way i can
cover more cases um
i also from early days since the for
each package has a lot of
a lot of packages and cram uses for each
i think they're like seven
eight hundred packages and we have like
plier carrot
glm net so i
dynamically tweak their examples and
i so they run through the to future back
end
and that way it also allows me to run
all those packages and their examples
through um the future framework so that
lots of ads more test cases and then i
mentioned before there's the
conformance validation of the parallel
back-end sets
there's a separate package future.tests
this was supported by our consortium
grant before i became a member
there i should say but this allows you
if someone writes a new parallel back in
for futures
they can run these tests and make sure
it works
okay so let's
um say so what
what doesn't work so not everything can
be paralyzed
and by the way feel free if there are
any questions
um break at any time here i don't know
there might be lots of questions already
um so
the not everything can be paralyzed and
you will
discover that
depending on what packages depend on but
a very simple case is this
connections in r so here is an example
that runs
parallel multi-session we open
a temporary file and then
we open a connection to temporary file
to write to this
and in the main r session we
write the letters hello to this file
then the next step we create a future
that
adds world to this connection and then
it returns 42.
and this will work they will launch the
future however when we
ask for the value we're going to get an
exception from this parallel worker
saying hey
that is an invalid connection because
this connection object is only valid in
the main r session
we actually passed it down to a worker
where this doesn't make sense
and luckily in this case it actually
detected is invalid
you can actually end up writing to the
wrong files here
r doesn't have a very good protection
mechanism for this because
connections are basically just index
numbers
zero one two three four so if you
already have
if this is connection three in the main
r session
and if you already had a connection
worker that's three it would actually
happily write to that connection
and this is really hard to protect
against but
we can try and this is not just for the
future framework this is true for all
publication frameworks in our
you can ask our future framework to say
scan scan for
potential problems among your globals
and if you detect that the potential
problems is a reference pointer
throw an error so by default it just
silently ignores it
and if we had this option set uh the
future framework will actually
before it sends it over to the worker
saying hey i detected a non-exportable
reference
it's called the connection it's a class
of file
uh and this is not this
enabled by default this check because if
you have a very large global objects it
might take a very long time to do this
but also there are some false positives
so if you would
do for instance a data table object
it actually has a external reference
pointer internally
but it's fine to pass that object
because the data table package
is clever enough to fix that
when you serialize and send it to a
parallel worker so but if
we had had set this to error
the future framework would prevent you
to sending that object
so we we can unfortunately not do this
automatically
another one and these becoming more and
more common
as more low-level libraries are
get their corresponding r apis so xml2
for instance the xml object so if you
create an xml object
say this is of course a toy example but
if you lead
read an xml file from the web or locally
and if you try to parallelize this
you're going to get external pointer is
not valid
and if we look at the content of this
object that we tried to send over
uh so the con it is sent over but then
on the worker it tried to process it and
it doesn't make sense
because it contains external pointers
and those are only
valid in the our process
where they were created and there is a
vignette for the future package that
tried to do a collection of all common
cases so if you discover new ones
i will be happy to add those there
and the way how we resolve this
in some cases we can work around it
if you want to paralyze over this object
of course i think
the only thing you can do is to read
this object
use read xml within the parallel worker
because you can't export this other
cases is like you can
work with the package developer and they
might not have thought about it and
maybe they can come up with a workaround
just like
data table does um
the the scary part here is that there
are some cases
where you don't
the the package that actually you
creates this and uses it in parallel
worker
doesn't detect this so you might
actually core dump the work or an even
worse case you actually get
random results back
so if anyone out there knows how to
protect against that i would be very
happy to hear about that
okay so
roadmap what's on the horizon here um
thing that's been asked for from day one
it's
uh you launch things you launch big jobs
and it takes forever
you launch maybe 10 parallel workers and
you immediately discover oh no
i did a mistake i want to restart it
um how there's no way to terminate those
launched futures um and
um it's it's
um it's a bit philosophical because it's
uh
basically the future api doesn't have a
concept of a worker it only has a
concept of a future
but there might be ways to to get to
this and one here is a
mock-up it doesn't exist but can you
imagine you have
you have two functions that perform the
same calculation
uh very slow and another one called also
slow
but you don't know which one is the
fastest so if
if you can spare the cycles you can just
launch this in parallel
at the same time and just see which one
is ready the first so
if you launch this in parallel and say
hey
you check future two are you done
and if it's done yes collect the value
and then here you want to say
now i'm no longer interested in the
first future so we need a
mechanism to say discard the first
future
and depending on the parallel back and
you run
this might be able to actually terminate
that
interrupt that future and free up those
cpu cycles
and but it might not work too because
it's
maybe you could work this run terminate
a running worker on
a remote machine somewhere by ssh in the
background and
sending an interrupt signal it could
also be that this
we run futures in
linux containers are sandboxed so as
soon as we launch them
we can't reach them it's like a security
thing
so you might not be able to tell that
linux container to stop you just have to
wait for it to finish
so this this are things i'm thinking
about
but it takes a very long time to get to
so every new release
there's something updated internally
towards these goals
another thing with this like if you can
terminate futures is like
if you use a mapreduce call
and one of the elements gives an error
then that future call will return that
mapreduce will result in error
and there's no point in having
all the other elements chunks keep
running
but in today how it works now we just
have to wait for
in this case the slow 42 and slow 31 and
slow pi
work whereas the slow of the string pi
failed so it would be nice if you can
detect this and terminate running
workers and
throw the error then and just be more
efficient
another thing that is also
i wish we can figure out how to
do it and slowly we're getting there
um so if there are i call it extreme
events so when you do parallel
processing you will run into things like
internet goes down so you lose the
connection to that
remote worker so that worker is gone so
if you try to
reach that later you get a
non-communication
communication fail there you can have
power outages
if you run big hpc clusters there might
be other users running on the same
machine
and they might run some software that
brings down that machine so it has to
be rebooted and it's then it's a bummer
if you have to
you might have been running things for
days and if one of your futures
fail how do we handle that so the future
package detects those types of errors
when it can't
communicate and here is an example if
you actually launch
a future in the background and call quit
and this can be done and of course that
will quit that background workers r
session
so when we ask for the value there is no
longer a communication with this
background worker and the error will say
yeah the process id no longer exists and
i conclude it's the process died
and we can use those as we can catch
those for exception handling like for a
future
error class and uh the thing is what can
we do here
ideally should we restart the worker if
it's a power failure
uh can we can we relaunch the future
and then the question is what does it
mean to relaunch a future
uh what does it mean to restart a worker
because that concept doesn't exist
necessarily in the future api but maybe
it exists
that the apparel back-end and uh
other questions like how should these
type of errors
be handled in higher level map map
reduce apis like future apply and fur
that's not clear it's it's a design
question philosophical question
because in the end of the day we want
everything to work
as similar as possible as it would when
you run sequential code
so okay
another very common question
is to pre-populate workers with data
and this is one place where futures
don't cover that case because they don't
have a concept of a worker
because future can be sequential they
can be in parallel
but here is an example
we launch for parallel workers and we
have a very huge
object and we're going to
do calculation on that object in
parallel on the workers
many times so the most efficient way is
then to export that object once to the
cluster workers
and then we called par l-apply um for a
certain set of parameters
and then we call it again with another
set of parameters
and the nice thing here is like we only
need to export huge ones
because that might be this might be a
substantial portion of the
uh parallelization overhead so we don't
want to
keep re-exporting it unless we have to
so as i said by design the future it
doesn't have the concept of a specific
worker so
we never know where a future will run
we don't know a lot of parallel
back-ends are
um not persistent they like the call are
they launch a process evaluate the
future and shut down
so there's nothing there's no worker to
cache things over time
but so in when you use future l apply
for instance a fur
map in this case the object huge will be
exported each time
here so that's unfortunate um
trying to come up with thoughts about
how to do this
so it fits the model and one is
something called sticky globals
and basically you might be able to
specify
uh future cash huge and you
maybe there we can have a language
construct but basically
you tell the future which
ends up on the worker saying feel free
to cache this object if you can
if you have that feature built in
so the next time we call it um if the
backend
has this object cached it would
um the framework will not send it over
and of course you can imagine that's
there's going to be negotiation it's
like
before sending exporting this object it
will
calculate some checksum it will
communicate with a worker do you have
this object cached
and is that yes i have this same object
with same checksum
you don't have to send it no i don't
have it send it over
so that kind of infrastructure has to be
added
and on on the developer's end
it has to be uh encapsulating very very
simple constructs that works
regardless of parallelization back end
so this is another thing work on the
roadmap
okay so let's wrap
up if you're interested in
trying out parallelization frameworks
feel free to try the future framework
it's it's a 15 years of
trying to improve on the existing things
mostly worry free you will run into some
things and if you do please ask and
we'll try to help you
it's meant to be right once and run
anywhere
uh global variables automatically taken
care of same as packages
standard outputs messages warnings are
automatically captured and relayed
here i mentioned progress too i have
appendix slides but we we can save that
for later
that actually shows you can do near live
progress
updates so you can have progress bars
etc
through a package called progressor
users are allowed to decide on
what their computer resources are so if
you write your code
as long as it does use futures for
parallelization
that user can use big compute clusters
or the cloud or whatever your code will
work there
there are some it builds some atomic
building blocks
three different the future value and
result
and from those three all the higher
level
polarization apis are constructed
and it's 100 cross-platform
thank you
if i stop sharing thank you very much
does everyone have a big virtual
applause for henrik
um i'll do my little try to get near the
microphone someone can hear
i hope everyone had a great time and i
learned a lot i've been using
i've been using parallelization for a
long time in r um
i came up using the um yeah i knew steve
west then he wrote parallel and i do
parallel
so i was using his stuff i know we
unfortunately lost him this year i
believe
yeah yeah it's uh
his work is amazing yeah he's
i didn't say that here it's he laid a
foundation of these thoughts and models
of thinking about it
yeah yeah he really did and um where i
learned brian lewis
had like sit over my shoulder and
because he was really good friends with
steve sat over my shoulder
doing this before he each do this and
really walked me through and really
expanded my uh
knowledge and since then i've been using
future and everything and so it's really
nice to see where we've come
for those who don't know steve weston
from i want to say the new haven area
connecticut
he wrote the parallel i'm not sure is
the parallel package or the dew parallel
the various types of parallel henrik you
probably
know more than i do he wrote the for
each and then they do parallel came with
those yeah
got it god yeah and that was
revolutionary that was the only really
great way to do parallel you know five
years ago until future came along
uh so we have a bunch of questions so
we'll see how many
i didn't interrupt you in the middle
because you're in a flow and a fairly
okay let's keep going if more questions
come in i'll add them to our list
um so you had an example where you have
para you wrote your own parallel l apply
and you said at the end of it you had l
apply of fs comma value where you call
it value on
and the whole future objects now if
because when you did the first l
applying that f function it
uh it returns instantly now when you do
value is that l apply running
sequentially and if one the first one is
blocking all the rest don't show up yet
that's a very good question so that's
that's uh yes it does of course
um so um
if your very first one takes the longest
you can't collect the values on the
other ones so you have to
wait you pay that overhead of collecting
values
and if they're big objects it might take
some time that's where you want to use
resolved so you want to check in on
those future are you done give me the
value
otherwise i could so behind the scenes
on fur and future
apply there's a lot of this
orchestration going on so
it does could be the next question that
takes care of it all like imagine
there's a while loop
and checks resolved and then collects
them and if we use future l apply a
future map we don't have to worry about
that
exactly and that same for loop also
which was a major work last year this
standard output when it releases it
it's trying to relay the in the same
order it was created
the same word as the loops are done
which it does
but it also tries to do it asap
so it yeah it's a lot of tat
yeah yeah tallying there going on all
the things that hopefully
the users don't have to think about
hopefully uh
since you just mentioned this actually
segues into another question
any discussion about the differences the
merits between
future l apply versus future map
um i think that goes more to
the way they work now that's like asking
like
l apply versus per it's that's that's
what it comes down to uh
and then they just happen to run in
parallel okay so that was
gonna be my guess all right yeah and
that's where i wanted
the future api to go one day it's uh
yeah
right yep um i guess along the same
lines can you compare i guess
it's probably the same answer um can you
compare do parallel with due future
i can um so do parallel
is um it does either
the mcl apply framework internally or
the parallel apply and it's it's an is a
bit unfortunate
it's uh it checks if you're in windows
it does one and the other one
and the future framework had that until
last week we had something called the
multi-process
which did multi-core if you were on
linux and mac os
or multi-session on windows and finally
we decided that's not a good idea
because it's
it's too ambiguous um so but so
two parallel has that same thing but
that that's a minor thing
um it's so do parallel has the same
strength and weaknesses as mcl apply and
parallel apply
whereas if you say do future it will
take care of the output and the warnings
and the conditions
it will also take care of globals
this is something i don't know if it
should so it's actually an option
now because if you write for each code
and this steve weston's idea is that the
user decides on the
backend adapter to register so if i
write code that the future framework
takes care of the globals
and then the developer is sloppy and
assumes
it will work then the user uses another
back-end
to parallel and it won't work so
this is the discussion we have to have
with the for each developers and i had
it slowly over time but
and we're trying to merge things there
but it's um
so i think you can i mean since i wrote
the future framework it's like
i i think i used to do future
yeah but it's um
and then i guess someone has a good pun
what is the future of
parallel or the parallel package
um that's that's a good question
uh it's a good pun um it's
something i'm working on in parallel uh
no but it's it's uh there are certain
low hanging fruits i don't know if you
check in the ardeville list like a few
days ago i i actually extracted a lot of
things from the future package to the
package called parallelly
because there are a lot of small
low-level orchestration that i think
should
be done by parallel package which i
just did in the future so i took that
all out from the future package to
separate package
and by doing that i hope some of those
would slowly
get into parallel bug fixes and stuff
but i mean it's parallel package has a
a lot of great ideas the parallel apply
has a lot of great ideas and
for me working with this future
framework in five years i tried to
reverse engineer luke tierney's thoughts
and he i can see he has a lot of great
thoughts in there too
but we don't have a common de facto
standard how to use it
um so unfortunately there's like
different ways of using it
but it's a great it's a great package
i think for new users i'm gonna guess
future is gonna seem
simpler to them i hope so yeah
um yeah um and you mentioned
multi-process i'm going to go back to
that because
i've realized i've had some issues we're
using multi-process
in our markdown document in our studio
um this was a few months ago and i'm
assuming that you've got rid of
multi-process to avoid those types of
issues
so i guess i'll segue to the next
another question here
um how does all this play nicely in our
markdown dock in general since i know
multi-process caused issues
how do we let's say you're writing our
markdown document you're on a windows
machine but you're deploying to a linux
machine
how do you get the stuff in there to run
a parallel on both your machines
um i'm not sure i understand the
question says
if you have within them are marked out
you just have parallel
calls that would just work
yeah that would work um
if you're saying you send off
to processed markdown object in a
parallel
i think the question was in a single
markdown document
if at the top you say library future uh
plan multi-session or multi-core um
and we want this markdown document to
work either on linux
or on windows is a way to do that
without your own because it used to be
multi-processing
okay yeah yeah i mean so then i so
because of that whole thing with the
fork
processing might be unstable um we
recommend and i think we it's me and
davis now he came to the same conclusion
he's like
it's it's nice to document and show one
line
but it might it's a bit ambiguous and
some people might run into problems that
others don't
so use multi-session multi-core you
should only use when you really know it
works
and i want to say that if you if you
write that
markdown or our script or our package
using
and you call another package and two
years from now
that package introduced some
multi-threading or something that causes
multi-core to crash
you have no control of that so
it's yeah so avoid multi-core
that actually brings up a great question
uh
that you triggered i know i've had
situations where data table which is
multi-threaded
has crashed hard on me um when i'm doing
that in parallel i think now data table
automatically detects if you're running
something in parallel and turns off
multi-threading
have you seen them i didn't know they
cut that
far i was so i'm a big proponent of
saying run
everything sequentially by default
because more and more things are running
in parallel
and we might actually fry the cpus if we
don't we're not careful
i should also say that as you might know
the future framework
tried to protect against that but you
can't do too much but
that's cool if they if they manage to
detect that if they see if you run in a
fork or a child process that it falls
back
i read that in some form somewhere that
they start detecting
exterior parallelism to turn off their
internal one oh that that's brilliant
it's uh
we've been playing around um there's an
optional thing um i forgot exactly what
that package is called now
it can disable the what's it called now
open mpi and not open mpi openmp
um so if
the if you do a future and it runs on
another computer
you already paralyzed on eight cores or
on another
core eight cores then it tried to set
those to use one thread um if it can
uh so it's trying to be very
conservative
and i have an issue i have like one
machine a few machines actually where i
use software-defined networking which is
a vpn but like it's a peer-to-peer vpn
completely defined by soft
but i know by the software and if i ran
things using openmp and it took over all
my cores
i lost connection to that machine
because there's no compute left to
actually run the network connection
wow yeah that's yeah yep and then
and you don't want to discover that
after four days of processing
or when your machine is in a physically
different location and you can't get
there because of coven
yep yep happened to me a lot until i
finally relocated the physical machine
and now sits under my desk for now yeah
no it's a lot of interesting things when
it comes to distributing parallel
processing to get things
robust which is a nice segue to another
question
can you do nested parallelism as in
federate out to different machines and
have each of those machines use multiple
cores
yes uh so i didn't show that so i i've
been using that a lot
in my cancer research so we have a
compute cluster
um one with 2000 cores which is like
30 machines we have another one with now
10 000 cores so
i have the first layer of
parallelization it can be for instance
if i have 100 patients and i want to run
analyze the genome across the 24 25
chromosomes
i use the first layer of polarization
across patients
and i throw that out to the job
scheduler
so each patient becomes a future
that's submitted to a job scheduler and
the job scheduler will then launch that
future
and internally i then
when i do that i request i want to have
25 cores
so when that future launches it will run
25 local course wherever it ends up
okay uh so that's the case we do nested
parallelization
you can specify that with the plan
function oh
using tweak or something right yeah or
so you basically
can specify a list so you can do
a list of so by default it's only one
level and if you anything below
becomes sequential if you don't specify
so you can do list in this case i first
element in list is a batch tool
uh backend and the second one is a
multi-session
nice that's really cool and you have an
example online
i've seen an example somewhere that you
say that but as you know you'll have a
sample somewhere
i definitely have and i can probably
pull it up
straight away it's uh giving me
here uh yep i'm going to share my screen
quickly okay
here is an example so
as you said there's a tweak
so this is actually not in a scheduler
this is saying a cluster
of a predefined set of nodes
so i call that an ad hoc cluster if i
have access to
50 machines myself and no one else got
there
so the first layer saying allowed to use
a cluster of these machines and then the
second layer
use multi-process now that's
this is an old slide so it should be
multi-session
and uh yeah uh that might be uh
other things but the the idea here is
that this is using the future assignment
but here is like an outer loop over
fastq that's the patience
and then here i create my first future
this one so that will now
be launched on one of these machines
and then i run over 24 chromosomes and
each of those runs
in a second level of futures very nice
yep that sounds very cool thank you for
sharing that
alright let's see what else we got here
um uh
you mentioned that you test on solaris
didn't cran solaris die
but they revived it i think oh they did
it yeah
it's um i'm not sure if they actually
revived it might be in modern versions
so the big engine
little engine thing might actually i
don't know
so i know that's a debate it's a pain
when you get hit by those
um but uh
yeah it's very frustrating at times
because it's really hard to reproduce
and you can't just like trial and error
you can do that a few times but then
but somehow i do things
like have testing on very obscure
environments actually improves the
quality for all of us
i do believe that i know a lot of people
cheered when the solaris
machine died yeah and and there is the
rhab uh
service provides solaris two different
things yeah so
that's where i can test more live okay
and so many people are using this you
know cool is still using it
um there's this question from our
next month speaker i believe um and and
but if you already answered he said how
exactly does one automatically detect
a non-exportable reference but you
answered that he said so
um he was in the chat i just want to let
you know that he asked that and that you
already know
i mean but i also tried to say is like i
can't but
in most cases the ones that call
external pointers
they fail but they don't always fail so
and you can scan for external pointers
when you
through the serialize function so
when you call serialize you can do a
hook function and as soon as the
serialize
detects the external pointer it calls
the hook function
okay so that's that's how i do it
well we'll hopefully that uh yeah that
influenced a little bit
um so when you're doing parallel
processing and you get an error
and it seems like it gets captured and
uh
it doesn't not everything stops like if
you do l apply you get one error the
whole thing stops
this thing doesn't stop so let's say you
have five elements in your return list
one of which is an error
how does that show up in the returned
list does it show up as an error object
is it just not there is an element is it
a four element list now
so so this i mean this question is for
future apply and i guess the same for
fur
and also for each so this is more a
design thing it's like
so if you ask the same question for
heliply
what what would the api for l apply be
if saying
i want everything to run how should
but how should what other arguments
should there be or options for
returning one error out of 100
so that's a matter of designing how that
should look like
um and right now i took the easy part as
a future apply
package emulates the base r l apply and
etc
exactly as is so i don't have to worry
about that
someone else can maybe figure out how we
extend that
i think fur he takes the same approach
he's like
exactly like perv because if you start
adding features
right then someone say hey i want those
features in per
or l apply so we need to be careful
there
so i think one solution is in the for
each package
um there they have uh forgot what the
argument is
but there is like on error or something
you can choose to throw an error error
i think that's the default uh you can
also say
uh ignore it like drop it which is kind
of weird
so if you call you expect hundred values
you get 97 back and you don't know which
one you don't get back
uh and then there is also returned
error object so i think that
that might be a solution to bringing in
um handling these kind of errors for
large processing then
so but then the next question is like
how do you bring in
the concept of orchestration errors
power failures
that's that's uh that's another type of
who should take care of those so and
then people start asking can you
automatically retry
and maybe we can but you don't want to
keep retrying to the end of the world
uh so you need to like maximum three
free tries and stuff so
it's it's complicated to design an api
for that
yeah but um yeah but hopefully
if we don't come up with it someone else
can figure it out
open source yep uh we have a question
about they would love an explanation
on the difference between futures and
promises they're familiar with promises
from javascript and they're trying to
resolve the terminology difference
because i know there's actually a
promises package and there's also our
promise objectives have been in our
forever so i think that's what they're
thinking about coming out a few things
here so it's a good question so
in our promises so i don't know
javascript
but um i'm pretty sure that it's not the
same type of promise as javascript has
so let's leave aside the promises
package uh so
the concept of a promising are
we kind of actually used quite often i
think um
if you want to look at it there is a
function called delayed
assign by the later assignment
so i can say calculate
one plus two and assign it to
variable a but do it for a delayed
assignment
then what happens in r that a
doesn't hold a value three it holds a
promise
to calculate the expression one plus two
and that is a construct
look deep down in r and that
i think that allows it to do um
various kind of laser evaluations so you
can you can set up like a
a one plus two b this than this but if
you never use a
and b you don't spend time calculating
them
so so it's it's just
like when you ask for the value it will
resolve it so the promises package
i think is more like the javascript uh
which i think is has this like um
so it's i think it's an unfortunate name
in that sense but
it probably fits better into the
graphical user interface with shiny
that's why it exists
um um so the promise is there
um and that can be used with futures so
you can create a future that
uses the promises package and
yeah you can probably see my hands here
i don't know uh
i was waving when i gave my talk to i
don't know but it's uh
so they're underlying the promises
package is actually an
event loop running too
which is in a package called later
so this is really cool it's also very
scary
but that's required in user interfaces
like shiny
so it's actually loops over this promise
and see is it done when it's done it
resolves it
or it's it's yeah so it's um
sorry i can't give a good explanation
for that
that's joe chang should explain that
yeah we'll get him here one day
yeah we will yes he's long overdue for a
talk
um then uh do you do you know how
plumber uses future so one of your sizes
showed it so someone's asking
do you know how plumber does it i
actually don't i don't i never launched
plumber myself it's i know it's a
dependency
and my reverse dependency checks i run
it every time
so it's uh yeah all right then the
similar question
do you know how the tidy models tune
package what back-end it's using if
it's using so i've i've talked to max
about this yeah and
he said i can use do parallel or do
future and but do you have any more
insight than that
i i don't i mean he the carrot used uh
for each so yeah i might go on there but
he has davis
who wrote fur so who knows he's sleeping
over there it's uh
yeah max uses underscores now instead of
camel case so i i mean i don't know if
you saw my slides but
i used to be very picky about naming
conventions
and when i started r you couldn't use
underscores
yeah it's that old yeah i and i came
from the java world also so i was like
okay camel case
um which by the way is better for screen
readers i heard
yeah yeah but so i used camel case
and then i started to use
underscores and now i'm one of those
people that
has a mess sometimes so sorry about that
yeah both capital case and underscores
together no
no yeah no i know capitals is in the
beginning i think no
not yet except accept classes classes
are capitalized like java yeah
yeah like java i've definitely been
guilty of combining one variable name
both camel case and underscores for
different parts of it because they
explain different
things yeah all right um just a few more
if we
if you still have energy in time i have
energy these are brilliant questions
it's fun
what is this uh someone's asking they
must have saw it somewhere what is
future.magic
what magic um
maybe they misread one of your slides
was it in the slides or was it like in
on the interwebs i have a question
someone asked what is future.magic um
i mean it could be maybe i wrote that i
think
you know what i think um maybe it was
like were you showing me
some of your tests or reverse
dependencies i think i vaguely remember
something something there
i saw future dot something um well
i don't know okay but maybe yeah i mean
maybe it's one of my
magic future packages fair fair enough
uh we have a question about
why do you suggest not to use detect
cores for m c apply
okay uh oh and someone does say they saw
magic somewhere in one of your slides
someone
said their name starts with an a just
said that uh maybe
was it that presentation i did today or
was it the different one
today oh
future let's say magic
huh or maybe it was the magic
backing up and then i show this
ah no i don't know all right so someone
had to hunt you down and email you
uh so the other question that someone
asked um
parallel or detected why do you
recommend not using detectors okay
um let me
okay i'm not sharing my screen now let
me quickly put that up
it might be easier so the tech course
is um
it it hijacks all the cores on your
machine
okay so that's fine if it's your machine
and you're the only one and then there
is a pattern where people say
um you see that very common you see it
in our packages
saying let's leave one core aside so i
can keep working so it's
detect cars minus one
so just that is actually two problems
first of all there are machines with
only a single core
so if you do detect or minus one you get
zero
it's not common but you can have that
another one is detect course if you read
the help it can actually return
n a so you have to handle that so you
have to do something like
max one comma detect course
comma narm equal to true
so you cover those cases okay then you
submit this package to cran
and if you read the policies they say
don't test on more than two cores at the
same time
and if they have now 16 cores
and they might run like five packages
test at the same time
you might go under a radar
until someone discovers it and they yell
at you um
and then however then they get more and
more chords so they might run on 128
cards now
and then they fit more packages at the
same time and more package run parallel
code at the same time
so there might all of a sudden be like
10 packages running
detect cores equal to 128
and they're going to swamp that computer
so this problem of using detect cores in
a multi-tenant multi-process environment
is getting worse and worse and worse and
why i feel so strongly about it because
i'm at ucsf
i'm in the different compute clusters we
see software
r python that trying to be fancy
and default to run multi-core and takes
all the course by default
and it's super neat when you sell it and
you show it and you run locally it runs
very fast then
people want to run it but if you have 20
users on the same machine
it's going to fry the machine and no one
will be happy
cs admin will spend a lot of time trying
to figure out
why what's happening they have to like
look at code
and it's hard to reproduce and things
like that
so it causes a lot of headaches for cis
admins um
and so yeah don't use that and then
now i'm a salesperson you should use
future available course
which i now move to parallely but it
works still in future
so that works the same as detect course
but it
will also respect various settings
so if the user has set mccors for
instance to two
available cars will return to whereas
the tech course will still return 128.
the sys admin can set an environment
variable of course they have to know
about the future framework
they're saying by default it should run
one unless the user requests more
but more importantly available cars also
respect
various schedulers like slurm sg torque
so if they gave you run a job and it
gave you like four cores
available cars will turn four so
and on cran it will detect that it runs
our command check and it will only
return to you you all won't mess up on
crime
right so you don't want to do that yeah
and then speaking of course um
there's actually i have a follow-up
question on that and actually now it's a
two-parter because you mentioned
something
um i know that i've seen max talk about
this
but from a lot of machine learning
algorithms once you get beyond the
physical cores the virtual cores don't
give you much return on speed
yeah how does future steal virtual
versus physical
and also have you seen with detect cores
even if you say logical equals false it
still
gives you the account for virtual
instead of physical course
um so yeah so available course
only does what detect course do you can
i think you
i can't remember if you can ask it to
give logical to
um this is something i don't know enough
about uh there's like all this
hyper threading and everything goes on
there um
i think the only way there is like to
actually test it
but it's hard to test it in multi-tenant
environment you have to test it in a
it's it would be nice you could do you
could have some
learning algorithm so one thing i want
to build into the
future framework is to optionally
benchmark things so you can see how much
time it's been waiting for things and
orchestrating and
and if you could pull that data out and
summarize it you could
maybe run it with one core two core
three course five course and see where
on your machine what's the best one um
it's um very nice guys so again max has
done the benchmarks on
machine learning algorithms that's you
know max's specialty and he's definitely
trying especially for tree based
algorithms like xg boost
once you get past the physical course
you're just wasting cores at that point
which begs the question can you do 2xg
both running on all physical cores and
get the same benefit
oh yeah if you paralyze and run yeah i i
don't know
it's uh it's a very good question but
yeah
yeah i don't know that's for him yeah
all right um and i this is someone's
asking about
registering back ends versus plan like
do you still need to do any sort of like
with all the different plans do you have
to do
like register do parallel register
register do future for anything like
that
uh so you have to do that with the for
each uh let me show that
can i show this maybe i don't have it uh
so
you when you do the
when you load it do per do future
package uh
it doesn't do anything so it doesn't
tell by default
for each that hey use me now
that's the seems to be the standard to
say
you have to register that so you do
register do future so with that that
will tell for each framework
everything now should go through the do
future package
and the default in the future in the
future framework is sequential
so then you have to specify plan
multi-session as well so it's
two lines um i thought about having like
do register
and then put the plan inside as
you can do one line to call this but
that might be too confusing so with the
due future
there's no argument to you just say
register your future and then you set
the plan
okay now and you only need to register a
future
if you're using 4h you're using future l
apply future map you no longer need to
register
yes there's yep so all those register
functions are only for the for each
got it framework cool um the answer is
that's it we have two questions are
similar this one is a lot
longer um and this actually the last one
i have recorded i was unless someone
else asked is the last one i have here
um
some of they really like the package
they are having trouble
doing it successfully a large part of it
is they're getting an error that's along
the lines of
restarting promise evaluation and
they're wondering this has something to
do with using
r my sequel so trying to load in a lot
of data and they're doing
they want to use like future of db get
query of some query
um basically what is what i guess i'll
distill this to
what is restarting promise evaluation
and have you tried using things for
reading databases and
have an issue with uh so the restarting
promises i don't know where that is
coming from but i suspect
that you can't paralyze um database
objects
uh that's my best guess i'm going to
pull that up now
um i guess you could create the correct
the
connection on each worker instead of
creating one global connection
yeah so now you see my thing this is
from the the vignette
uh of non-exportable objects
i've read that and one of the examples
is dbi connection it's a
i mean it might not be this but
basically
here's like you set up the dbi
connection and then trying to
parallelize over this and this is just
saying
print the connection over in the worker
and they work
it will just not work here i did i'm
detecting there
i don't know if you actually let it run
on the worker it might
completely core dump the drake package
talks about this about how to do this
i remember yeah so there's probably like
yeah you have to launch
i can imagine you have to set up the
connection on each worker
to work that around and then you have to
make sure your database is parallel safe
of course so for instance i don't think
it's safe to use it on a
sql sqlite file
because i don't know if i don't know
where this if they
you can trust uh multiple workers to
write to the same file
in a safe way maybe postgres does his
own parallelisms imagine you're calling
postgres in parallel and it's doing its
own parallelism you get that race
condition again
yeah but i think i mean normal the big
databases they of course they can handle
uh actions or tasks from multiple
sources so
they should be parallel safe and
actually we got one more question
which actually seems like a nice way to
end this um all this parallelization
sounds tricky should it remain a last
resort
that's a very good point yes um
there's a i always say don't use
parallelization
did i end there no no but i mean you
have to be
don't there's a lot of things that can
be made faster
and a lot of code can be made twice as
fast and it can be done so recursively
if you spend a lot of care but at some
point it's like
you want to paralyze so you might not be
able to optimize the code you call if
you use another package
so um yeah save it
as a last resort but it's uh don't be
afraid of it
it's getting easier and easier i like
that i'm actually um
i am giving a talk at our conference i
talked about next next month
about taking a problem and combining
data table parallelization and rcpp
to take something from hours to seconds
but it took all three technologies
yep that's that's a very good example so
it's like
uh yep i did try parallel first because
that was actually the easiest for me to
do
believe it or not versus uh data table
and rcpp
yeah cool so with that um we saw one
there's one more comment
saying optimization about
parallelization is tricky yeah i'll buy
that
um everyone just says buy more computers
amazon alright anyway
so thank you very much for this
excellent talk
um i know i had a good time hope
everyone else did too uh if remember
we have our r week next month we have a
meetup we have workshops we have two
days of conferences
if anyone wants to attend ny hackard
gives you 20
if anyone has financial difficulties
just message us and we'll make sure
you we can get you in there ahmada am i
missing anything
um and also if you can also check out
the
diversity and inclusion scholarship on
rstats.aisle.gov
and if you are an artist you can submit
something to the art auction
yes and again the proceeds go to our
foundation so like everyone wins you get
cool art
and our foundation gets some money and
the artist gets to have their stuff
shown away and we got some really cool
artists on i think
thomas lynn patterson is uh you know
donated something
is vivian peng doing it again uh she
might
and we have a nadia bremer
and will chase um
and a few other selena carter yeah
thanks and that's on top of all the
excellent talks by the way andrew gilman
we all know this highly charged
political scientist will be giving a
non-partisan politically charged talk we
have something from nasa we have
um uh oh my gosh all these things are
escaping we've got our stats that ai
slash government see all this great
lineup with great people
uh it's gonna be a fun time that i
always like saying our conferences are
always fun
and informative so it's late on the east
coast it's later in europe
well it's not like it's depending on how
you need to find link anyway everyone
have a great night
we'll see you all next month and
ensuring months a big round of golf clap
for henrik thank you very much
that's really excellent and hopefully
we'll see all of you at our next uh
meetups and next events and hopefully
hendrick you'll keep joining the
community it's like i mean the reason
henrik spoke is cause
he came to a talk i saw him in the chat
window and i said you're giving a talk
and that's what happens sometimes i
think will speak next month he was at
the same talk they said
you're giving a talk that's what
happened so if you want to give a talk
say hi or if i find you in the comments
section you might get money back come
after you
so please do join us uh and if you want
to give a talk let us know
we're booked for a few months but we can
book you a few months in advance give
you plenty of time to work on this talk
we'll see you all soon thank you
everyone good night thank you so much
thank you thank you